und da sind sie schon die beiden
Hauptakteure Robert Habeck der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und Clara
gabitz die bundesbauministerin jetzt wie
immer am Anfang einer solchen
Pressekonferenz gibt's erstmal noch ein
paar begrüßungsfotos es geht natürlich
um die Frage Heizungstausch ab 2024 da
gab es heute einen Kabinettsbeschluss
und den werden die beiden Bundesminister
jetzt sicherlich vorstellen vielleicht
noch mal in diesem Zusammenhang ganz
bemerkenswert zu diesem
Kabinettsbeschluss bevor er jetzt
überhaupt vorgestellt wird gab es um
11:30 Uhr konnten sie auch live hier bei
Phoenix gesehen eine Pressekonferenz der
Opposition im Bundestag der Union und
dort hat man bereits diesen
Kabinettsbeschluss kritisiert und unter
anderem hat dort auch der
Fraktionsvize sparen noch einmal von
einem chaos-gesetz gesprochen und ja
jetzt wird es sehr spannend sein wie
diese beiden Minister das jetzt
eigentlich begründen werden und wir
würden jetzt mal rüberschalten nach
Berlin und hören rein in die pressekon
und werden das anschließend auch für sie
noch mal einordnen
den Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz Herrn Robert Habeck und die
Bundesministerin für Bauen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen Frau
klarer Gallwitz und sie haben uns
mitgebracht die Novelle des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes und das neue
Förderkonzept der Bundesregierung für
erneuerbares heizen
vorbeiwitz habe ich richtig verstanden
beginnt dann Herr Habig und dann kommen
Ihre Fragen bitte der
Koalitionsausschuss hatte festgelegt
dass er im April noch beschlossen werden
soll dass die g-gesetz in dem geregelt
werden soll wie in Deutschland zukünftig
geheizt wird und wir haben uns an diese
Frist gehalten es war eine sehr
intensive aber gute Zusammenarbeit in
der Bundesregierung und ich werde jetzt
einen regelungsinhalte des Gesetzes
vorstellen und dann wird Robert habe ich
auch noch vor allen Dingen die natürlich
sehr spannenden Aspekt der
förderungs skizzieren wichtig ist dass
dieses Gesetz dazu führen wird dass wir
in Deutschland unsere Heizung
modernisieren es wird nicht dazu führen
dass jemand ohne Heizung da sitzt und es
wird auch nicht dazu führen dass
Menschen gezwungen sind ihr Haus zu
verkaufen weil sie sich nicht an die
Anforderungen dieses Gesetzes erhalten
können das eine ist wichtig dass es
keine über den jetzigen gesetzlichen
stand zusätzlichen aus Frau Auflagen
gibt das heißt Heizung jetzt
funktionieren werden nicht ausgetauscht
und wenn die Heizung kaputt ist dann
kann sie natürlich repariert werden wir
werden allerdings regeln dass es in
Deutschland kein Einbau von reinem Gas
und reinen Ölheizung mehr geben kann ist
auch relativ klar wenn wir 20 55 45
klimaneutral sein wollen und so eine
Heizung gerne mal 20 Jahre hält dann
müssen wir natürlich den Einstieg in dem
Ausstieg des Verbrennens von fossilen
treffen es ist uns sehr wichtig gewesen
dass wir sehr intensiv auch fachlich
diskutieren dass es für jede denkbare
Konstellation in Deutschland ein
Regelungen in diesem Gesetz gibt es gibt
großzügige
Übergangsfristen es gibt großzügige
ausnahmefristen wenn das individuell
oder technisch nicht möglich ist es gibt
natürlich auch Regelungen für Häuser die
unter Denkmalschutz stehen das alles
wurde in diesem Gesetz berücksichtig
auch die spannende Frage die man zum
Beispiel mit Gasetagenheizung umgeht
jetzt ist sicherlich auch eine sehr
interessante Debatte warum wir diese
Form des ordnungsrechtes wählen
ordnungspolitisch zur Marktwirtschaft
passend sind natürlich auch
Anreizsysteme und eine Steuerung zum
Beispiel über CO2-Emissionen wenn man
sieht wie der CO2-Preis sich
prognostisch entwickeln wird wird
niemand im Jahr 2030 oder 35 auf die
Idee kommen sich eine Gas oder Ölheizung
einzubauen da muss man das gar nicht
verbieten sondern das wird dann so teuer
sein dass es niemand macht das Problem
ist bei langfristigen Investitionen wie
Gasheizung oder Heizung insgesamt z.B
wird durch die Marktteilnehmer diese
Preissteigerung nicht antizipiert das
hat man gesehen im letzten Jahr wir
hatten eine akut
gaspreiskrise wir haben über
gasmangelagen diskutiert wir haben den
Gaspreis mit Milliarden subventioniert
und dennoch wurden in diesem Jahr
600.000 neue Gasheizung eingebaut
und das ist natürlich wichtig für alle
die jetzt überlegen wie heit sich
eigentlich in Zukunft dass wir ihn als
Politik sagen dass man das über den
Lebenszyklus betrachten muss weil es
ansonsten auch verlorene Investitionen
sind und das ist ganz wichtig dass
dieses Gesetz klar macht es gibt eine
Lösung die ich sozialverträglich es ist
eine Lösung die aber ökonomisch auch so
sinnvoll ist und keine verlorenen
Investitionen bei den Hausbesitzern
verursacht und es ist natürlich ein
riesen Schritt auch hin zu der Senkung
der Emotionen im Gebäudesektor das
Klimaschutzgesetz hat mein Ministerium
beauftragt die gebäudeemissionen zu
reduzieren wir haben die Ziele in den
letzten Jahren fehlt und das heißt wir
werden natürlich auch sofort Programm
auflegen bis zum Juni wo wir noch mal
Maßnahmen skizzieren und da ist einer
der wesentlichen Maßnahmen dass wir
gerade im Bereich der Heizung
modernisieren und auch die schlechtesten
die ineffizientesten Heizungen in
Deutschland als erste austauschen und
natürlich war uns auch wichtig dass es
alles sozialverträglich ist und deswegen
wird dieses Gesetz flankiert durch ein
sehr umfangreiches Förderprogramm so
viel erstmal zu mir Herr Habeck
vielen Dank
Frau Gallwitz Liebe Clara erstmal danke
für die gute Zusammenarbeit und sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren bevor ich zu
den förderkonzepten erlauben Sie mir
auch noch zwei einleitende Bemerkungen
erst einmal es ist vielleicht jetzt auch
für die Öffentlichkeit das wichtigste
Gesetz dass heute das Kabinett
beschlossen hat aber nicht das einzige
es wurden gleichzeitig das Gebäude
Energieeffizienzgesetz das
Energieeffizienzgesetz und das
bundesmissionsschutzgesetz in einer
Novellierung beschlossen beides Gesetze
die umfänglich sind und die dem Zweck
die in den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
wünscht und Energieeffizienz
Energieeffizienzgesetz nach vorne zu
bringen in diesen Dreiklang muss man
unterstreichen dass der
Koalitionsausschuss solange er gedauert
hat wirklich Knoten und Blockaden gelöst
hat die Regierung zeigt dass sie Gesetze
verabschieden kann und es sind ja
durchaus anspruchsvolle Gesetze wie
gleich und das hat eben schon ausgeführt
wichtige Gesetze diese Wichtigkeit will
ich noch einmal kurz unter Bereichen
bevor ich zu ein paar Details komme der
Wärmebereich in Deutschland steht für 80
für 30 Prozent des Energieverbrauchs und
innerhalb des wärmebereichs sind 80
Prozent Fossil Energien die genutzt
werden Öl und Gasheizung vor allem Gas
aber auch noch ganz wesentlich Ölheizung
das heißt also dass wir da eine große
Aufgabe vor uns haben und wir fangen sie
vergleichsweise spät an andere Länder
haben das schon früher getan wegen der
Kälte des Winters will ich nur kurz auf
die skandinavischen Länder verweisen
dort ist das Verhältnis jetzt zum
Beispiel für Dänemark gesprochen genau
umgekehrt wir haben 80% fossile Energien
im Wärmesystem in Dänemark sind es noch
20 und 80% sind erneuerbare
das liegt auch daran dass häufig
entfernen wärme-systemen gearbeitet wird
ein Punkt der in der öffentlichen
Debatte vielleicht
gar nicht so im Mittelpunkt stand aber
sicherlich für den innerstädtischen Raum
großer Teil der Lösungen sein wird aber
sie nutzen eben auch dann die Technik
die jetzt im öffentlichen Fokus so stark
stand Wärmepumpen Norwegen zum Beispiel
60% der Heizung sind Wärmepumpen
Finnland und Schweden 40 Prozent und
Dänemark in diesem System dass sie
aufgebaut haben wollen jetzt ein Drittel
ihrer Wärmeleistung durch große Pumpen
leisten die Gebäude haben ungefähr den
gleichen bestand das gleiche Alter die
gleiche Substanz wie in Deutschland und
Finnland Norwegen und Schweden sind ja
nicht bekannt für milde Winter insofern
sehen wir dass viele Debatten die wir
hier jetzt in den letzten Monaten und
Wochen geführt haben in anderen Ländern
schon entschieden worden und anders
geführt worden beziehungsweise anders
beantwortet werden lange Rede kurzer
Sinn wir haben Handlungsbedarf da rein
gerade angesprochen und wir sind auch
international vergleichsweise spät dran
der politische Grund also dieses Gesetz
zu machen ist erstens anknüpfend an die
bauministerin Verbraucherschutz gestern
hat Brüssel noch einmal bekräftigt und
beschlossen dass der ETS2 so der
Emissionshandel auch für Gebäude kommt
das heißt es ist sicher dass die
fossilen Energien teurer werden
zweitens die Erfahrung des letzten
Winters Energie Sicherheit und Resilienz
zu erhöhen ich erinnere daran dass sie
noch nicht so lange her dass es eine
realistische Debatte und Befürchtung war
bleiben unsere Häuser kalt weil wir
einen gasmangel haben das sollte jetzt
nicht einfach der politischen Amnesie
verfallen und sagen na ja vorbei die
Lektion die dahinter steht nämlich eine
gewisse Unabhängigkeit herzustellen die
haben wir schon wieder vergessen dann
natürlich der Klimaschutz die
dekaronisierung und damit verbindet sich
aber auch eine investitionsoffensive
auch eine Innovationsoffensive
die verschiedenen Techniken die dort
hinführen können zu einer
Klimaneutralität sie müssen ja gebaut
hergestellt und eingebaut werden also
das stärkt natürlich auch den
Innovationsstandort Deutschland oder
Europa auf die Übergangsfristen und
Übergangslösungen hat Klara Gallwitz
hingewiesen ich würde gerne noch
erwähnen weil ja die Frage des sozialen
Ausgleichs ganz wesentlich auch beim
Koalitionsausschuss im Mittelpunkt stand
das für eine Reihe von
Menschen
Ausnahme Tatbestände die schaffen wurden
und das sind alle diejenigen die
Wohngeld Empfänger sind die Empfänger
von Grundsicherung im Alter sind im
Finger von Kinderzuschlag oder vom
Bürgergeld sind diese Menschen werden
von den Pflichten des Geige ausgenommen
damit ist sozusagen ein großer Teil
derjenigen die in beispielsweise selbst
genutzten Wohneigentum leben aber
geringe Einkommen haben adressiert und
von der Pflicht
freigestellt gleichzeitig wollen wir
natürlich diese Menschen teilhaben
lassen an den Möglichkeiten auch
erneuerbarer Wärme einzubauen und
deswegen wird die Förderung wie folgt
umgestellt im Moment haben wir über
verschiedene Module die sich aber auf
die Technik konzentrieren also
Wärmepumpen im Wesentlichen
einbaukasten der bis zu 40% der
Förderung ausmachen kann wir werden dann
in Zukunft 30 % als Grundförderung haben
für alle Techniken die gewollt oder
gewünscht werden und dazu kommen dann
wir nennen es sogenannte klimaboni der
hauptklima Bonus wäre eine Zulage von
20%, das wäre der klimabonus 2 der für
diejenigen die ich beispielsweise gerade
genannt habe also die Menschen die
sozial Transfers beziehen gilt auch für
die über 80-Jährigen oder für diejenigen
die in selbstgenutzten Wohneigentum
Leben und von der Pflicht des
Austausches entbunden sind also Öl oder
Gas oder gar noch Kohle Heizung haben
die älter als 30 Jahre sind also
erzielt auf die
auf die auf die Bevölkerungsgruppe die
möglicherweise mit den ältesten und den
schlechtesten Wohnungen befasst ist und
dann gibt es zwei andere klimaboni
jeweils eine 10%ige Zulage haben werden
sie adressieren diejenigen die von der
Frist des Umtausches erfasst sind aber
sie früher ausführen oder diejenigen die
bei einer Havarie stattfindet also ein
Gaskessel kaputt geht und dann eine
Wärmepumpe oder eine andere Technik
eingebaut werden muss die diese Frist
die die Möglichkeiten die dann
geschaffen sind ebenfalls abkürzen
also ein Anreiz schneller zu handeln mit
einer sozialen Staffelung die dort
eingebunden ist soweit von meiner Seite
danke ja dann kommen wir zu ihren Fragen
ich habe die ersten Fragen rechtsnotiert
und fangen bei dem Kollegen
rechts an sie hatten sich gemeldet ich
habe nicht alle Namen jetzt gegenwärtig
sehen nach und dann gehen wir zu der
Kollegin zwei rein Leute fahren bitte
danke schön die Hauptstadtstudio Herr
Habicht sie hatten ähm vor geraumer Zeit
mal gesagt bei der Förderung und beim
sozialen Ausgleich sie würden jetzt
ungern Leute fördern die sich selber
leisten können jetzt mehrfache
Millionäre gibt es ist in der Förderung
ich habe es bisher nicht gefunden
irgendeine Einschränkung vorgesehen oder
ist das was sie eben skizziert haben für
alle möglich und noch kurze zweite Frage
kann ich die Förderung durch die Klima
Bonus eins und zwei kombinieren oder
kann ich nur einen davon in Anspruch
nehmen
es ist nicht hart so dass die Förderung
nach oben hin offen ist das hat sich
[Musik]
das machen wir darauf haben wir uns
nicht verständigen können eine
Einkommensprüfung
durchzuführen und dann für Menschen mit
sehr hohen Einkommen irgendwo
abzuschneiden also das ist sozusagen für
alle dann nach oben hin offen
beziehungsweise also im Einkommen nach
oben hin offen bzw der Hauptschwerpunkt
lag darauf die Menschen die wenig Geld
haben erst einmal gar nicht zu erfassen
und zweitens dann trotzdem in die Lage
zu versetzen mehr Geld zu bekommen und
die Boni sind dann exklusiv also man ist
entweder im Bonus 2 oder im Bonus 1
wie hoch ist denn das Fördervolumen und
die wollen Sie sicherstellen dass
Haushalte finanziell nicht überfordert
werden und wenn ich das richtig sehe ist
diese Förderung im Haushalt ja auch noch
nicht finanziell hinterlegt und Herr
Lindner sieht die Finanzierung ja auch
nicht als gesichert an
die Finanzierung ist gesichert das Geld
kommt aus dem Klima und
transformationsfonds ist ja ein Fond der
der Jährlichkeit des Haushalts entzogen
ist von den verschiedenen Ministerien
die im Klima transformationsbereich
unterwegs sind jeweils in scheibensäulen
oder Fenstern bewirtschaftet wird die
Säule in der wir uns jetzt befinden ist
das sogenannte big das wird federführend
von meinem Haus gemacht aber wir stimmen
uns immer auch eng mit dem Haus von
Klara gails ab in diesem weg-programm
gibt es ja jetzt schon die skizzierte
Förderung dann von Wärmepumpen mit den
genannten bis zu 40% über Modulen die
sich aufbauen dazu kämen jetzt von dem
Volumen die Menschen die bei einer
Havarie beispielsweise austauschen
müssen und das sind so die werden etwas
höher sein als das was wir jetzt für
Anschlag haben aber so um die wir im
Klima Transformation zwar abbilden
können
und dann genau Andreas Kock RTL eine
Frage
ich habe das vernommen was Frau Gallwitz
gesagt hat warum sie sich sozusagen für
diesen Weg entschieden haben für das
Ordnungsrecht und eben nicht vertraut
haben auf die Effekte des Zertifikate
Handels aber warum aus mit ihren Worten
würde ich das gerne noch mal hören das
warum muss man jetzt sozusagen diese
harte Vorgabe machen ab nächstem Jahr
eben keine Gas und Ölheizung mehr das
zum einen und wie bewerten sie denn die
Protokollen Notiz von dem man gehört hat
worauf eben die FDP Minister abheben
dass man eben doch Stärke noch auf
Praxis Tauglichkeit Finanzierbarkeit und
eben Technologie Aufenthalt setzen soll
also einmal nur politisch ins Gedächtnis
gerufen dass wir eine Regelung für den
Neueinbau noch einmal darum geht es ja
klar jetzt hat das gerade noch einmal
betont Neueinbau von Heizung schaffen
werden die dann ein Mindestanteil von
65% Erneuerbaren haben steht schon im
kollisionsvertrag also unabhängig von
dem was meine persönliche Meinung ist
oder was ich für geboten halte sind wir
natürlich auch erstmal daran gebunden
den Koalitionsvertrag einzuhalten das
ist dann vorgezogen im Angesicht der
Drohne Energiekrise des letzten Jahres
also schneller energieeffizient zu
werden auf das Jahr 24 so wie jetzt der
Gesetzentwurf ist vorsieht ich
persönlich habe die politischen Gründe
noch mal versucht zu nennen es ist
erstmal und das sollte nicht verkannt
werden Verbraucherschutz das heißt auch
dafür zu sorgen dass man keine viel
Investitionen schafft ich weiß darauf
hin dass der jemand dass der ETS dazu
führen wird dass die fossilen Energien
teurer werden die Sicherheit der
Klimaschutz und die Innovation
Freudigkeit der Unternehmen auch hier im
Lande anzureizen
die Protokollerklärung habe ich zur
Kenntnis genommen ich das sind Punkte
die haben wir alle beredet wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt nicht weiter
uns
einreden durch bestaunen eines Problems
wird irgendetwas besser und die Frage
die ja häufig nicht beantwortet wurde
ist was denn sonst also wenn man sagt
ihr könnt weiter
ein Problem man kann die Antwort ja
schlechter Dienst nicht sein weil es da
ein Problem gibt oder Fragen auftauchen
bauen wir weiter Gas und Ölheizung ein
als gibt es keinen Morgen und da ist
heute ein wirklicher Schritt gegangen
worden und ich bin mir bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass dieser Schritt dann
auch zu einer schnellen Verabschiedung
im Deutschen Bundestag führen wird oder
klar also vielleicht noch mal ergänzend
in der Marktwirtschaft sind natürlich
Steuerungsinstrumente zu bevorzugen die
genau die positiven Märkte hervorbringen
in dem Fall handelt es sich aber
natürlich aufgrund der fehlenden
Transparenz für eine Form von
Marktversagen weil diese
Steuerungsfunktion noch nicht da ist
weil die Menschen ja aus Jahrzehnten
erfahren haben Gasheizungen sind die
billigsten und man jetzt auch nicht
voraussetzen darf dass jeder der
Verbraucher ist und sich eine Heizung
kauft das was Robert Habeck gerade über
den europäischen
Emissionshandel berichtet hat dass er
das schon antizipiert und bis ins Jahr
2030 vorausgegennostiziert das sozusagen
der
verbraucherschutzaspekt und das andere
ist wir haben versucht diese
marktregelungen zu implementieren auch
jetzt in dieser
gg-regelung indem wir eine absolute
technologieoffenheit geschafft haben
indem wir halt nicht gesagt haben es
gibt nur diesen einen Weg sondern wir
alle technisch überhaupt denkbaren
Möglichkeiten zugelassen haben damit
genau der Verbraucher entscheiden kann
wofür ich zum Beispiel diese staatliche
Förderung einsetzt und das heißt sie
kriegen die 30% egal welche Heiz die
Technik sie sich auswählen sie kriegen
den Bonus 1 und 2 auch egal welche
Technik Sie auswählen und Sie können
dann selber entscheiden ob sie eine
Wärmepumpe haben wollen Solarthermie
einen Wasserstoff Heizung oder aber eine
Holzpelletheizung und insofern versuchen
wir das im kleinen nachzuziehen das ist
halt diesen Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
innerhalb der unterschiedlichen
Technologien gibt was ist halt nicht
geben sollte aus unserer Sicht ist ein
weiteres zubauen von neuen Gasheizungen
weil wenn wir sehen letztes Jahr 600.000
neue Gasheizung dieses Jahr nächstes
Jahr über nächstes Jahr und sie haben
dann die CO2 Bepreisung dann wird wir
auch immer
2027/28 politische Verantwortung trägt
das Problem haben dass da Menschen
niegeln neue Nagel Gasheizung haben und
sich den CO2-Preis nicht leisten können
dann müssen wir das entweder Weg
subventionieren über einen
gaspreisdeckel den man aber auch nicht
ewig bezahlen kann oder man muss ihn
dann einen Bonus geben damit sie ihre
neu Gasheizung austauschen also insofern
ist das natürlich gerade in so
transformativen Umbrüchen sehr schwierig
diesen Prozess marktwirtschaftlich zu
organisieren wir haben das aber gesehen
bitte kurze Nachfrage noch aber wer ist
nicht schlauer gewesen erst mal diese
auch von Ihnen genannten Techniken und
ein wenig in den Markt kommen zu lassen
das stärker zu fördern und diesen diesen
harten Einschnitt dann einfach nach
hinten zu setzen einfach zwei drei Jahre
was ich gedulden und dann die Markierung
zu bringen
also zum einen Holzpelletheizung und
andere Sachen Solarthermie das sind
alles Sachen die sind ja jetzt schon am
marktgängig das was in der Tat jetzt die
große Frage ist welche Zukunft hat
Wasserstoff im Bereich des Heizens da
gibt es erste Modellprojekte wie sich
der wasserstoffpreis entwickelt das
werden wir sehen auf der anderen Seite
haben sie dann natürlich auch immer bei
diesen technischen Umbrüchen die
Situation wenn man jetzt noch zwei drei
Jahre
die Einführung nach hinten schiebt dann
hätten sie erstens über eine Million
neue fossile Heizung und das zweite ist
natürlich das ganz viele Verbraucher
sagen würden jetzt baue ich mal noch
schnell eine Gasheizung ein und dann
haben sie lauter verlorene Investition
erzeugt und das ist volkswirtschaftlich
nicht sinnvoll und natürlich ökologisch
auch nicht
sagen darf meine Analyse wäre er wir
sind sowas wie 10 Jahre zu spät anstatt
2 Jahre zu schnell mit Blick auf das ist
europäische Ausland macht und schon
gemacht hat die Nerven Ende habe ich als
zitiert und wir haben ihre Entscheidung
nach der letzten großen Energiekrise
also in den 70er Jahren Ölkrise
getroffen und seitdem dann gesagt wir
verabschieden uns von der Technologie
weiter fossile Energien einbaut das
heißt die Technik ist reif
so ich glaube ich hatte am Anfang da
rechts noch eine Frage gesehen war das
bei Herrn Vitzthum oder hinter ihm ja
dann sind Sie dran dann gehen wir in die
Mitte zu der Kollegin
ja Fabian Busch von web.de und GMX ich
würde gerne noch mal bei dem nachhaken
was Frau Witz gerade gesagt hat welche
Alternativen gibt es denn jetzt zur
Wärmepumpe wenn man die nicht einbauen
kann oder will was immer so genannt wird
Biogas Wasserstoff fernwärme ist ja gar
nicht überall oder für alle verfügbar
ja im Prinzip sämtliche denkliche
denkbare Lösungen wichtig aus meiner
Sicht werden auch
Hybridmodelle das heißt sie haben eine
Grundversorgung zu 65 Prozent erneuerbar
und haben dann vielleicht noch ein
fossilen Kessel mit dem Sie dazu heizen
ich weiß vor kurzem in Altensteig mitten
im Schwarzwald ganz stark unter
Denkmalschutz stehend und auch da haben
sie es geschafft zum Beispiel mit
lokalen Nahwärme netzende Versorgung zu
machen es gibt die Entwicklung hinzu
groß
Wärmepumpen und natürlich denke ich auch
das Geothermie in Zukunft eine größere
Rolle spielen wird und das Gesetz ist
zwei teilig aufgebaut ist eines ist
listet ähm technisch mögliche
erfüllungsoptionen auf wenn man die
einbaut dann ist es automatisch eine
Erfüllung des Gesetzes Unternehmen gibt
es eine innovationsklausel wenn man
irgendeine Form von noch nicht also
sozusagen kannte Heizung hat kann man
die auch zertifizieren lassen und gilt
dann auch als Erfüllung und weiß dazu
natürlich gerade auf dem Land immer die
wichtige Frage ist was ist eigentlich
mit dem Kamin auch in Zukunft wird man
natürlich einen Kamin haben können und
auch ein Kamin wird angerechnet mit zehn
Prozent auf die Erfüllung des eeg-ziels
und natürlich werden auch
Biomasseheizungen eine Rolle spielen
gerade im ländlichen Bereich
bitte Ihre Frage
Herr Habeck zwei Fragen zum einen ein
Detail hybrid-heizungen mit Öl sind noch
erlaubt bei dem Gesetzentwurf ist jetzt
die Rede von gasflüssig Brennstoff und
Biomasse aber nicht mehr von Öl und die
Grundsatzfrage warum kombinieren Sie das
nicht mit dem Gesetz zur kommunalen
wärmeplanung also warum nehmen Sie die
privaten Hauseigentümer ein Jahr früher
in die Pflicht als die Kommunen
ich kenne keine Hybridmodelle die Öl
nehmen
sonst ist eben wichtig dass die 65%
eingehalten werden das bemisst sich dann
über den Wirkungsgrad der Wärmepumpe
also die klassische Einwendung wäre
schlecht saniertes Haus
große Wärmemenge notwendig eine
Sanierung scheidet jetzt aus weil es in
das Leben nicht reinpasst oder
vielleicht zu teuer ist aber man kann
von September bis
Dezember gut miteinander Wärmepumpe
klarkommen bei einem durchschnittlichen
Winter aber im Dezember im Januar nicht
aber Februar März April gegebenenfalls
wieder und dafür gibt es dann eine
Zusatzleistung die dann auch fossile
Energien und das wären dann Gasthermen
nutzen kann und die wärmeplanung nehmen
deswegen wirkt sich klar wird schon
rüber ist auf dem Weg die beiden Gesetze
sind auch logisch eng miteinander
verknüpft hier setzt die das Gebäude
Energiegesetz bei der einzige Erfüllung
des Hauses oder das Haus besitzt das
Vermieters wie das Eigentümers an oder
Eigentümerin die kommunale wärmeplanung
schafft
das Umfeld dafür und die Kommunen müssen
sich jetzt Gedanken machen viele tun das
ja natürlich auch schon und viele
Bundesländer haben ja schon längst an
der verpflichtende kommunale
wärmeplanung eingeführt wie soll denn
das Wärmesystem in der Zukunft aussehen
das Gesetz braucht auch dieses Wissen
weil beispielsweise wer sich in einer
planbaren Perspektive wir haben jetzt
zehn Jahre reingeschrieben an einem
Fernwärmenetz anschließen lassen kann
kann jetzt ebenfalls für die
Übergangszeit weiter für viele Energien
also Gasthermen oder gegebenenfalls
würde ich jetzt schon abraten aber auch
sogar Öl benutzen aber da muss man eben
auch eine verbindliche wärmeplanung
haben und das können nur die Kommunen
leisten jeweils in der
Ausdifferenzierung beide Gesetze müssen
zusammen gedacht und auch zusammen
gemacht werden das ist aber auch
unterwegs
gleichzeitig 20 25 das hätte doch der
Akzeptanz sicherlich geholfen unser Ziel
ist dass die kommunale wärmeplanung das
Gesetz dafür noch vor der Sommerpause
ins Kabinett geht aber Frau Rolle haben
sie unterliegender mit einem Irrtum ist
es nicht so dass das GEG für die
privaten Hausbesitzer ist und die
kommunale wärmeplanung ist dann für den
Bereich der Öffentlichkeit sondern die
kommunale wärmeplanung soll gerade die
Grundlage dafür schaffen dass nicht
jeder Hausbesitzer einzeln überlegen
muss wie heit sich in Zukunft sondern
dass die Kommunen diese
potenzialplanung übernehmen dass sie
auch die Daten Wissen von den
Gewerbetreibenden zum Beispiel dass Sie
wissen wie viel Abwärme wir in dem Ort
haben das
Energieeffizienzgesetz ist dann
wichtiges weiteres Puzzle und natürlich
wird es nicht so sein dass wir von heute
auf morgen in allen Kommunen eine
kommunale wärmeplanung haben wir müssen
bei allem was wir machen in diesem
Transformationsprozess die
Planungskapazitäten immer mit
berücksichtigen so dass es auch eine
staffelte wärmeplanung gibt und in dem
Fall ist es so wie Robert habe gesagt
hat wir sind jetzt nicht überall sondern
wir sind eigentlich spät dran wenn man
sieht dass einzelne Bundesländer schon
kommunale Wärme Entfernung verpflichtend
haben dass der Bund jetzt dieses Gesetz
auf den Weg ist hoch notwendig damit
dann auch die Verfügungsstellung von
dekarbonisierter Wärme eine
Daseinsvorsorge der Kommune ist
dann ist hinten
danke zwei Fragen wenn sie abends zum
einen sie sparen von einer guten
Zusammenarbeit der Bundesregierung wir
erklären sie sich denn dann die
Protokollerklärung von der Lindner der
ja praktisch auf einer Seite
zusammengeschrieben hat was ihm alles
umsetzen nicht gefällt und im Grunde der
Bundestagsfraktion der FDP Aufruf noch
mal massiv dagegen vorzugehen wo war da
die gute Zusammenarbeit und hat einen
Punkt daraus genommen es geht um die
Grenze der 80-jährigen die er für
verfassungsmäßig schwierig hält oder
eine gute Begründung können Sie
vielleicht beruhigen das sozusagen die
eine Frau und die andere Frage geht noch
mal um die
das Abschalten von alten Heizung die
fdp-regler mit für sich dass sie den
Erfolg gehabt hat dass in dem
Gesetzentwurf jetzt nicht mehr drin
steht das weitere Heizung außerhalb der
alten Ölheizung die 30 Jahre alt sind
etc abgeschaltet werden müssen ausnahmen
werden müssen also vielleicht zur
jetzigen Gesetzeslage noch aus der alten
großen Koalition es gibt im jetzt
existierenden GG eine Austauschpflicht
für konstant temperaturkessel Gas und Öl
betrieben deren Besitzer nach dem ersten
Februar 2002 das Haus übernommen haben
die müssen nach 30 Jahren diesen Kessel
austauschen die davor sind aus Gründen
des härtefalls ausgenommen aber wir
haben ja gesagt das ist ja für die
Besitzer dieser Heizung keine gute
Nachricht dass sie aus sozialen Gründen
ausgenommen werden von der
umsetzungspflicht weil das führt ja dazu
dass sie in Zukunft höre Nebenkosten
deswegen machen wir das erste Mal dazu
auch eine Förderung das heißt die die
sowieso schon jetzt gesetzlich
verpflichtet werden auszutauschen ganz
kleiner Teil also Konstanz
temperaturkessel deren Besitzer nach
2002 das Haus erworben haben kriegen
jetzt eine extra Förderung damit sie
dieser alten noch von der Vorgänger
Regierung stammenden Pflicht zustimmen
das zweite ist die Frage des 80-jährigen
das ist ganz wichtig dass man weiß auch
im 79-jähriger in 78 schwieriger oder
auch ein 20-jähriger kann nach Artikel
102 des Gießen Antrag stellen
ausgenommen zu werden wenn es eine
individuelle Härte für ihn ist und wir
wollten einfach natürlich den
Genehmigungsbehörden aber auch den
80-jährigen die Bürokratie ersparen und
haben gesagt bei Ihnen machen wir eine
Pauschale Fiktion des Gesetzes dass es
für sie nicht zumutbar ist und natürlich
ist das ein Gesetz was die Gemüter
bewegt da haben ja auch einige
Medienvertreter auch in den letzten
Tagen die Stimmung aufgenommen oder auch
geprägt und das wird natürlich im
Bundestag nicht nur bei der FDP-Fraktion
sondern auch bei den Grünen und bei der
Sozialdemokratie intensivste Debatten
geben aber noch mal wenn sie sehen wann
der Koalitionsausschuss war dass wir
eine Osterpause hatten und dass wir
jetzt hier sitzen und das Gesetz
vorstellen und auch eine abgestimmte
Förderkulisse haben wenn das keine gute
Zusammenarbeit ist dann weiß ich auch
nicht hin
vielen dank zwei Fragen und zwar
schnelle das Geld kommt aus dem
klimatransformation ist das eine
Förderung die endlich ist wie viele
Förderungen aus dem Ministerium auch
weil irgendwann stellen wir mal fest das
Geld ist weg und wie klimaneutral sind
Wärmepumpen die mit Kohlestrom betrieben
werden vielen Dank
die dass der klimatransformation speist
sich immer wieder aus den Einnahmen des
ETS also das Zertifikate Handels oder
der CO2-Abgabe das heißt im fließen
immer wieder Geld dazu und dann das
werden sie wissen sind in den letzten
Jahren immer wieder
sonderzuweisungen Restmittel aus Corona
Investitionsfonds dem überführt worden
das heißt es kommt immer wieder Geld
rein es kommt immer wieder Geld fließt
immer wieder Geld ab für die großen
Programme ich war gestern auf der
Hannover Messe wir haben einen großen
Stahlwerk einen großen Scheck überwiesen
gibt es
festgelegte Scheiben die natürlich immer
auch wieder angepasst werden können weil
Preise sich erhöhen oder weil
Unternehmen rausgehen und sagen wir
brauchen doch gar keine Förderung aber
im Prinzip ist das ein ein wie soll ich
sagen ein System
rausgeht und jetzt stocken wir innerhalb
dieses großen Volumens des KTF die
auf um das alles bedienen zu können das
sind aber in den Summen die wir da
bewältigen darstellbare zum also
insofern da ist es meiner Sicht keinen
Grund zu Besorgnis und
die
der Energiemix in Deutschland beträgt im
Moment 50 Prozent
das wird nach kleiner Regierung in den
nächsten sieben Jahren auf 80 Prozent
hochgehen in den Regionen natürlich
unterschiedlich Wärmepumpen werden Strom
getrieben wir gucken jetzt aber nicht
auf die einzelnen Regionen haben aber je
nach Bauch zu überfreundlicher sind sie
das ist ja jetzt keine keine Schreiben
der Status Quo ist super natürlich ist
das auch die große Baustelle aus der
Kohle verströmung auszusteigen trotzdem
sind die Wärmepumpen klimafreundliche
auch jetzt bei dem bestehende Energiemix
als jede Öl und gasheizung
die Förderung die sie vorgestellt haben
bezieht sich ja auf selbstgenutztes
wohneneigentum wird es auch eine
Förderung für nicht selbst genutztes
Wohneigentum geben und daran
anschließende Frage an Frau gayverz
Vorgabe zwieb wollen Sie verhindern dass
es jetzt zu massiven Mieterhöhungen in
Form von modernisierungsumlagen kommt
wenn dann eben gerade in Mietwohnungen
die Heizungen ausgetauscht werden erst
einmal gibt es neben den Förderung auch
jetzt schon im Weg die Möglichkeit
steuerliche Abschreibungen vorzunehmen
das ist alternativ also da muss ich dann
entscheiden was man will und die Frage
ob man diese steuerlichen Abschreibungen
noch mal ausweite das ist dann
wahrscheinlich für Vermieter auch
durchaus interessant dafür größere
Investoren die konnte und kann jetzt
nicht nebenbei geklärt werden Sie wissen
dass wir kurz dass wir eigentlich jetzt
anfangen mit den Haushaltsberatungen und
das der Steuertopf auch knapp und
umkämpft ist aber es gibt schon jetzt
eine bestehende Förderung und die wird
sicherlich nicht geringer werden dafür
und für die ähm für das nicht selbst
genutzte Wohneigentum gilt dann die die
Förderung wie eben beim Big erst einmal
dargestellt ob wir das für Vermietungen
noch anpassen das werden wir bei der
Programmierung des BG entscheiden
ja mit Blick auf die Zuständigkeit auch
der Länder in Steuerfragen ist die Frage
des der steuerlichen Förderung für
Vermieter eine Sache die wir jetzt mit
den Ländern auch weiter noch aus
diskutieren werden da wird es auch dann
entsprechend ein Setting geben der
Förderung für Vermieter und das Ziel ist
natürlich eine warmmieten neutrale
Modernisierung wir müssen natürlich
wissen dass das was für private
Hausbesitzer gilt nämlich das ein
schlecht saniertes Haus mit einer alten
Heizung in Zukunft sehr sehr viel teurer
wird als jetzt dass das auch für den
vermieteten Bereich zutrifft wir haben
nur eine einzige Unterschied und zwar
ist es so dass natürlich der private
Hausbesitzer immer automatisch
zusammenrechnet die Summe für die neue
Heizung und die Betriebskosten für die
nächsten 30 Jahre und das fällt
natürlich im vermieteten Bereich
auseinander da trägt der Vermieter die
Investitionskosten kann sie teilweise
Kollegen die Nebenkosten rechnet er aber
bei Mieter ab und deswegen haben wir
einen technischen Mieterschutz in diesem
Gesetz eingezogen das heißt sie können
zum Beispiel nicht nur Wärmepumpe in ein
Haus bauen was nicht saniert ist und
dann trägt quasi der Mieter die
Nebenkosten oder was man zum Beispiel
machen könnte ist ja eine
stromdirektheizung ist extrem billig
aber ist natürlich extrem teuer in die
Nebenkosten und deswegen gibt es in
diesem Gesetz ein technischen
Mieterschutz alle anderen Fragen des
mietrechtes werden dann natürlich von
dem geschätzten Kollegen Buschmann
bearbeitet der ja fürs BGB zuständig ist
ja auch noch mal zwei Fragen zum Thema
Kosten es müssen auch eine Schätzung
geben wie stark der Haushalt jetzt durch
dieses Förderprogramm im nächsten Jahr
in den nächsten fünf Jahren belastet
wird eine Gesamtsumme muss man ja mal
ausgerechnet haben also das würde mich
mal interessieren zum einen und zum
zweiten was passiert eigentlich mit den
Gasleitung es sind ja glaube ich 500.000
km Gasleitung die wir haben mit deinem
Wert von 60 Milliarden Euro die ja
hinfällig werden die stillgelegt werden
müssen in den nächsten Jahren
wie will man da den Eigentümern helfen
was haben Sie davon
ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen das
ist aus dem Klima Transformation das
Geld wird bereitgestellt also nicht aus
dem laufenden Haushalt nicht steht nicht
im Konkurrenz
aber trotzdem muss ja eine Summe geben
ja das ist eine Summe aber die ist habe
ich ja schon jetzt mehrfach gesagt die
ist überschaubar weil ja ich schon jetzt
eine Förderung da ist und ich habe
gedacht 40% jetzt jetzt setze ich anders
zusammen 30 bis 50 Prozent in der
Förderung dann da und es kommen eben die
Liegen mit rein die in der Havarie
beispielsweise jetzt nicht mehr
Gaskessel geht kaputt können Gaskessel
einbauen können das ist aber gut
darstellbar und aber konkreter als
überschrauber gibt es keine Zeit ja wenn
dieses genau programmiert haben gibt's
die Zahlen
aber die politische Ansage ist ja es ist
darstellbar und das Geld ist vorhanden
und die
die gasnetzfrage hängt natürlich ganz
wesentlich jetzt von der kommunalen
wärmeplanung ab das wird ja auch sehr
unterschiedlich sein das Baujahr wird
unterschiedlich sein die
Abschreibungszeiten werden
unterschiedlich sondern auch die
Nutzungsmöglichkeiten werden
unterschiedlich sein es ist ja darauf
hingewiesen möglich
Wasserstoff zu nutzen ich glaube wir
beide wenn ich dich mit äh will ich
sprechen darf haben gewisse Zweifel dass
das die Kosten günstigste Lösung ist
also ich halte das für eine sehr mutige
Ansage oder Überlegung wenn Stadtwerke
ihren Kunden sagen wir machen mal nichts
machen alles mit Wasserstoff
das muss am Ende ja alles bezahlt werden
und im Moment sind die Preise auch die
preisskalierung noch nicht so dass man
daraus ein günstiges Angebot ableiten
kann zumal die Bedarfe der Industrie ich
verwies schon an den auf den
Förderbescheid den ich gestern
überreicht habe also
Stahlerzeugung auch Stromerzeugung statt
Gas enorm sind
aber bitte am Ende geht es uns um
klimaneutrales heizen und das macht dann
durchaus unterschiedlich sein und Insel
Lösungen beispielsweise kann ich mir
tatsächlich auch vorstellen Nähe von
Gewerbeparks oder im ländlichen Raum wo
Elektrolyse stattfindet dass man da
einzelne Wohngebäude anschließt aber es
wird unterschiedlich sein und andere
werden da vielleicht anders drauf gucken
dass ich ja auch okay
insofern findet in Teilen sicherlich
eine Umwidmung statt und einen anderen
Teilen wird ein alternatives System
aufgebaut werden wie Fernwärme
beziehungsweise die wenn das Wärmepumpen
Strom geführt sein soll dann über die
Verteilnetze eine Ertüchtigung
ja vielleicht noch mal zur Ergänzung
oder das total nett dass du für mich
mitspricht aber gerade im Bereich des
Wasserstoffs haben wir da doch natürlich
gerade was den volkswirtschaftliche
Betrachtung anbelangt bei dir natürlich
eine andere Schwerpunktsetzung als im
Heizungsbereich ist es ja so dass wir
ein sehr großen wasserstoffbedarf haben
werden und ist einfach Branchen gibt die
haben keine andere technische Lösung als
ihre die Karbonisierung Strategie über
Wasserstoff zu machen ich denke da zum
Beispiel an die Zementindustrie und
andere die sehr viel Wasserstoff
brauchen werden und deswegen kann man
natürlich sagen im Gebäudebereich gibt
es gängige andere Alternativen und dann
muss man den kostbaren Wasserstoff nicht
zum Heizen verwenden so jetzt wenn man
natürlich den Wirtschaftsminister fragt
der betrachtet das ganze System ich sage
natürlich aus meiner Sicht wenn es
Möglichkeiten gibt vor Ort Wasserstoff
zu nutzen zum Heizen und das für den
jeweiligen Besitzer oder die Struktur
die Region eine sinnvolle Sache gibt da
gibt es die ersten Modellprojekte dann
wird das natürlich aus meiner Sicht zu
dieser
marktkonform Technik offenen Lösungen
mit dazugehören ich war jetzt auf der
Leitmesse ISH in Frankfurt da sind die
Anbieter unterwegs wir werden natürlich
aber genau unterschiedliche
Anbieter haben die einen werden die
karbonisierungsstrategie in ihrem Netz
haben andere werden das nicht haben und
diese
Umstellungsphase wird natürlich sehr
herausfordernd sein weil in dem Moment
wo sich immer mehr jetzige
gasheizungsabnehmer vom Netz abmelden
hat man natürlich steigende Grundkosten
und das wird dann für die verbleibenden
Netz Teilnehmer so teuer dass die dann
umsteigen das heißt in diesen
Transformationsprozessen hat man langsam
zum Anlauf und dann eskaliert es oder
skaliertes nach oben weil man dann
natürlich die Marktmechanismen hatten
und sie haben ja die Frage gestellt wie
viel kostet das Ganze das ist natürlich
sehr schwer prognostizierbar weil wir
aus gutem Grund nicht eine feste
Förderung geben weil immer wenn man eine
feste Förderung macht dann wird das
natürlich eingepreist bei denjenigen die
das dann verkaufen sondern wir machen
eine prozentuale und wir sehen jetzt ein
riesigen Aufbau von
wärmepumpenkapazitäten so dass man davon
ausgehen kann dass wir dadurch wenn wir
jetzt 30% fördern und die Wärmepumpen
einfach deutlich preiswerter werden in
den nächsten Jahren mit der gleichen
Summe Geld ist einfach eine größere
Transformation und Modernisierung
anstoßen können
ja zwei Fragen zum einen zur Förderung
noch mal ihr Gesetzentwurf enthält ja
sehr detaillierte Berechnungen über die
Lebenszeit der Heizungen das eigentlich
in allen Fällen eine Wärmepumpe bzw
manchen Fällen eine Pelletheizung die
günstigste Variante ist und die
Mehrkosten bei der Anschaffung über die
Lebensdauer wieder eingespielt werden
mindestens deswegen meine Frage wozu
braucht man eigentlich diese hohe
Förderung wird es nicht eigentlich lang
einen zinsfreien Kredit über diese 18
Jahre die da ist mindestens als
maximaler motivationszeit angegeben sind
reinzunehmen und dann rechnet sich das
für jeden auch so und die zweite Frage
das was er denkt ja eben fragte was aus
meiner Sicht noch gar nicht beantwortet
dass er Lindner jetzt eine Stunde
nachdem das Gesetz das Kabinett passiert
hat sich auf Twitter schon wieder davon
distanziert und ich mich schon noch mal
interessieren wie sehr nervt sie das
eigentlich dass man sich jetzt zum
vierten Mal über dieses Gesetz geeinigt
hat und dann ist es immer noch nicht
geeinigt
also das
Bundeskabinett entscheidet immer
einstimmig kein Gesetz für lässt das
Bundeskabinett zu dem nicht alle
Ministerien ja gesagt haben und mehr
dazu ist gar nicht zu sagen dass das
Parlament
diskutiert und sich Fragen stellt und
Antworten gibt das ja auch keine neue
Nachricht also insofern
mehr ist dazu eigentlich gar nicht zu
sagen und die Berechnung die wir haben
bei den jetzigen Preisen sind inklusive
der Förderung also die Amortisierung ist
in der ist mit der Förderung gedacht und
die Förderung wird aber wenn wir sehen
wie sich die Wärmepumpen entwickeln
natürlich dann
irgendwann wenn die Wärmepumpen den
Preis von Gasheizungen haben dann auch
wieder runter gehen oder weiter runter
gehen aber das ist im Moment nicht der
Status Quo sondern im Moment wäre ist
die neue Technik halt teurer und
entsprechend übernehmen wir einen Anteil
und haben das versucht so zu kalibrieren
dass gerade diejenigen die knappes Geld
haben besonders gesehen werden
gut dann ist Herr Jung dran und dann
Herr Bollmann
was haben Sie in den letzten Wochen über
Äußerungen aus ihrer Koalition gedacht
die gemeint haben dass sie nächstes Jahr
Oma Erna die Heizung rausreißen wollen
das haben ja FDP Abgeordnete öffentlich
gesagt und haben sie überlegt die
Wärmepumpen in e-pumps umzubenennen
damit man die FDP davon überzeugt
nein ich habe versucht zu argumentieren
dass das niedergesetz und vorgesehen hat
dass die Möglichkeit zu Reparatur
natürlich auch immer schon davor da war
aber nun glaube ich ist die Debatte auch
schon weitergegangen und vor allem bin
ich sehr zufrieden und
das darf ich vielleicht zu offen sagen
hätte dass mit dem Verlauf der Leute
auch nicht immer für möglich gehalten
dass wir jetzt in diesem früher das
Gesetz verabschieden und damit eine
Chance haben das auch noch vor den
Sommerferien durch die beiden
gesetzgebungs kann man zu bringen und
das halte ich auch für erstrebenswert
weil das ja ab 24 greift so dass also
gesetzgeberische Klarheit allen hilft
also insofern ist das wirklich ein
besonderer Schritt den das Kabinett
heute gegangen ist und ein großer
Lügen gefragt haben sie jetzt nichts zu
gesagt und Frau geibels meinte vorhin
dass sie jetzt eine Sofortprogramm
vorlegen will wird passieren auf den
Klimaschutz gesetzt weil sie ihre Ziele
wieder gerissen haben Herr Wissing aber
Herr Wissing muss das nicht und das
ganze Amt hat das abgesegnet warum muss
ich der Verkehrsminister nicht mehr an
das Klimaschutzgesetz halten woraufhin
er ein Sofortprogramm vorlegen muss aber
Frau Geiwitz schon als lange Nachteil
ja ich bin ja nicht die Pressesprecherin
von Volker Wissing da müssen sie ihn
schon selber fragen ich bin die Chefin
des baumministeriums das Bauministerium
hält sich an die geltenden Gesetze des
Klimaschutzgesetz sieht vor dass wir in
so einem sofort klar machen wenn das
Klimaschutz geändert wird dann halte ich
mich anders geänderte Gesetz das ist
auch selbstverständlich und vielleicht
noch mal ein Punkt das sind natürlich
jetzt alles
Umwälzungen wo wir jetzt auch auf dem
sinnvoll ökonomisch und ökologisch
effizientesten
Fahrt sind und wenn man zum Beispiel die
sektorziele im Gebäudebereich sich
anschaut wenn wir jetzt eine große
solardachinitiative machen dann dient
das nicht der Emissionsreduktion im
Gebäudebereich weil das kommt dem
Energiebereich zugute wenn ich was ich
vorhabe mit German Özdemir eine
wunderbare holzbauinitiative mache
diente es nicht dem
emissionsbereich des gebäudebereiches
sondern einem anderen und deswegen sage
ich auch mal das ist alles keine exakte
Wissenschaft sondern wir versuchen hier
eine große Industrie Nationen zu
transformieren und das mit möglichst
solchen Instrumenten die zu unserer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft passen und wenn
wir jetzt feststellen beim
Klimaschutzgesetz dass wir uns selber
regeln gegeben haben die nicht unbedingt
logisch sind weil natürlich ist das ein
Beitrag des gebäudesektors wenn wir
jetzt möglichst viel erneuerbare
Energien auf Häusern produzieren dass
wir CO2 einsparen dann kann man dieses
System auch noch Nachschärfen und das
werden wir machen und solange das Gesetz
nicht geändert ist halte ich mich an das
geltende
ja ich wollte noch mal nachfragen zu der
Forderung der FDP oder von Herrn Lindner
eben technologieoffenheit in Bezug auf
Wasserstoff erhalten Sie das denn
überhaupt für machbar und realisierbar
also als zum einen wäre ja die Frage
sind dann darf man dann Gas Thermen auf
den H2 ready drauf steht noch einbauen
nach wie vor und zweitens wir sind wir
haben jetzt über die Abschaltung das
schon gesprochen die könnte denn so eine
Umstellung auf Wasserstoff überhaupt
technisch aussehen wenn da parallel noch
eine Menge Gast haben dranhängen die
eben nicht für Wasserstoff geeignet sind
also das Gesetz ist technologieoffen hat
vor ein paar Minuten ein bundesale
technischen Optionen aufgezählt und
entscheidend ist am Ende dass es mit 65
Prozent erneuerbaren betrieben wird
dafür gibt es Fristen die gelten jetzt
nach dem Gesetzentwurf und ich halte das
für Weise für
Fernwärme Systeme wie für mögliche
wasserstoffsysteme parallel also
2035 sollen 65% erneuerbar in den
jeweiligen Systemen dann sein das wäre
auch der
Anspruch an mögliche Nutzung von
Wasserstoff das heißt wenn man sich aus
Gründen entscheidet auf diese Technik zu
gehen und die kommunalen
Anbieter sagen wir werden das beliefern
sie stehen dann auch in der Pflicht das
zu liefern dann soll der Anteil des 35
bis 35 erreicht sein von heute also in
12 Jahren gemessen an der
Geschwindigkeit die wir hinlegen müssen
erreichbar
und bezogen auf die Klimaneutralität das
Fehlen dann ja immer noch 35 und es
werden nicht alle sein auch richtig denn
wir haben schon darauf hingewiesen dass
wir 20 45 klimaneutral sein müssen 2045
klimaneutral kann aber logischerweise
nicht so funktionieren dass wir bis 2044
nicht klimaneutral sind und vom 31.12
auf den ersten wird auf einmal alles
umgestellt das ist ja total unplausibel
sondern das wird eben
erwachsenenzubau geben und das haben wir
versucht zu spiegeln wie sich das in der
Wirklichkeit auswirkt haben wir eben in
den Möglichkeiten und in den
in den Konkurrenzen gespiegelt aber wenn
die Frage ist ist das gesetzlich öffnen
ist das ja
so ich habe jetzt noch fünf Fragen
notiert ich weiß nicht ob alle dran
kommen weil wir für direkt BK dann noch
umbauen müssen die Kollegin hier hat er
sich gemeldet
Melissa Eddie von The New York Times
global gesehen sind Wärmepumpe nur im
Steigen Herr Habig sie haben schon
erwähnt in Skandinavien wir sehen Polen
Frankreich Italien nur in Deutschland
herrscht diese unglaublich sehr großes
Skepsis wir erklären sie das und warum
glauben Sie dass ihr Kampf dafür so C
ist
miteinander zusammen Deutschland hat
noch bis ins letzte Jahr hinein den
Einbau von fossilen Gasheizungen
gefördert sogar also
angesprochen das ist ja jetzt irgendwie
Kollektiv beigebracht worden das ist
eine super Technik und die
Handwerksbetriebe sind daraufhin
ausgerichtet wir haben kurz über die
Gasleitung gesprochen sehr viele
Kommunen haben die Netze ertüchtig
daraufhin ausgelegt und jetzt kommt auf
einmal die Ansage ganz du kannst nicht
weitergehen und das trifft natürlich
anders als bei dekarbonisierungsdebatten
wo man über kraftwerkstrukturen geredet
hat und dann quasi als Adressat drei
oder fünf große Konzerne hatte jetzt auf
einmal
Millionen von Menschen im konkreten und
sehr viele Stakeholder Kommunen
energiebetreiber und natürlich haben die
alle auch eigene Interessen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
berechtigterweise bei hohen Inflationen
wollen nicht überfordert werden die
Kommunen haben ihre Investitionen
getätigt naja und
wenn man jetzt ich habe ja die Zahlen
genannt wenn die Gasversorger in 20
Jahren kein Gas mehr verkaufen können
dann rechnen die natürlich auch und das
bilden sich in dem Bilanzen ab und aus
diesem Konglomerat ergibt sich natürlich
eine Menge von
höflich gesprochenen nachfragen und
politisch gesprochen natürlich habe ich
ein großes Verständnis dafür dass jetzt
wo wir eine Schubumkehr einleiten
nachdem noch bis ins letzte Jahr hinein
in die andere Richtung gefördert beraten
und aufgebaut wurde dass das schwierige
Fragen nach sich zieht das ja völlig
unstrittig deswegen finde ich auch noch
mal auf die Frage von den jungen
zurückgehend ein Teil der Debatte
richtig sinnvoll es gibt ganz viele
Detailfragen und die Lebens- und
heizungsanstände sind so unterschiedlich
wie die Menschen leben und wohnen es
darf eben nur nicht meine Ansicht nach
dazu führen das aus einem falschen
Verständnis dessen was eigentlich gerade
Phase ist nichts mehr passiert und so
erkläre ich mir das wir sind haben einen
einen eigenen Weg beschritten der hat
Millionen von Menschen betroffen und
jetzt
der Kollege in der letzten Reihe links
ist dran und dann gehen wir nach rechts
ich hätte noch mal eine Nachfrage zu der
Ausnahme aus dem 71i und zwar zu
Eigentümer von Wohnungen in
Mehrfamilienhäusern mit
Zentralheizungen die über 80 Jahre alt
sind die sind von der Ausnahme des 71 i
ausgeschlossen oder ist sie sind von der
Ausnahme ausgeschlossen also man über 80
ist muss man sich mit dem Gesetz nicht
beschäftigen
genau dann ist hier dann lautet meine
Frage was passiert wenn ich in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus eine Wohnung mein
Eigentum ist in der auch andere
Eigentümer sind was passiert mit dieser
zentralheizung
wenn es einem in einem Mehrfamilienhaus
eine garste Etagenheizung gibt dann sagt
der Gesetzentwurf in eine von denen
kaputt geht hat die
Eigentümergemeinschaft drei Jahre Zeit
sich auf einen System zu verständigen
und zehn Jahre Zeit das System
einzubauen
wenn die Zentralheizung kaputt geht
gelten dann die Pflichten des Gesetzes
eigentlich
so bitte letzte Reihe dann Herr Jessen
und Frau Haag und dann ist die Zeit
wahrscheinlich um
sie haben das Wort
nein sie hatten sich doch gemeldet oder
ja
sorry
dann ist wahrscheinlich Ende der Zeit
alles klar ist auch noch eine kurze
Nachfrage sie sagt mir eine soziale
Staffelung ist drin die haben sie ja
durch diesen Zusatzbonus für Wohngeld
Empfänger z.B ähm gibt es denn ein
Deckel zu irgendwie oder muss man damit
rechnen dass wenn ein willenbesitzer
jetzt eine große Anlage der einbaut dass
die Förderung auch die der 30%
Fördersatz bis ans Limit geht
das habe ich schon gesagt es gibt keine
Einkommensprüfung nach oben also es gibt
eine Einkommen ist klar aber eine
Deckelung die Deckelung auf die
förderfähige Höhe die wird die gibt es
aber es gibt keine Einkommensgrenze nach
oben also auch der
Normalverdiener und willenbesitzer wird
kein Unterschied gemacht sondern nur in
der Summe dessen was auf die 30 bzw 50%
berechnet werden kann
jetzt gesagt hat selbstverständlich lege
sie einen Sofortprogramm vor weil das
gelten Rechtslage sei in der vergangenen
Woche hat das Verkehrsministerium gesagt
muss nicht sein weil sich die Rechtslage
ändern wird sie sind nun auch
Vizekanzler sind sie denn der Meinung
dass die geltende Rechtslage für alle
Ressorts zu gelten hat ja und ich glaube
so ist es auch gemeint oder jedenfalls
gedacht gewesen ich glaube das ist da er
eine rhetorische Verwirrung gegeben hat
natürlich gelten gesetzliche Rechtslagen
für alle und vereinbart wurde das wissen
Sie ja dass das Gesetz novelliert wird
und bis es novelliert ist gelten die
entsprechenden Gesetze arg Zusatz kurze
Zusatzfrage ja kurze Zusatzfrage dass
sie vorhin auch sagten das kein Gesetz
verlasse das Kabinett wenn ich
Einstimmigkeit beschlossen sei dass du
an ihre Worte gleichwohl hat der
Finanzminister eine Stunde später
getwittert er erwartet nun das
notwendige Veränderungen von Parlament
beschlossen werden das heißt inhaltlich
war er nicht einig hat er denn im Rahmen
der
kabinettsberatung dieser aus seiner
Sicht notwendigen Änderungen angemahnt
naja ich lese es trivialerweise so dass
wenn Änderungen notwendig sind dann
sollten Sie auch beschlossen werden das
Kabinett allerdings alle ressortkollegen
eingeschlossen erkennen keine weiteren
notwendigen Änderungen und deswegen
haben sie heute so auf den Weg gebracht
Julia Zeitung
privat heizen mit Holzgas
ob sie eine Wärmepumpe einbauen und die
staatliche Förderung in Anspruch nehmen
und die zweite Frage wäre ob ich privat
heizen und die zweite Frage wäre sie
waren vorhin schon mal in der Richtung
unterwegs wie sie den Widerspruch
erklären zwischen der massiven Art
massiven Ausbau der gasinfrastruktur mit
flüssiggasterminals und dieser
Aufforderung an die Bevölkerung die
Gasheizung rauszubringen ich liebe in
einer Stadt Flensburg die ein
fernwärmelsystem hat und zwar ich glaube
stattdeckend das ist in den 60er Jahren
so entschieden worden und ich nehme an
die Nähe zu Skandinavien hat geholfen
weil das ja die skandinavischen Städte
gemacht haben ich will noch einmal
unterstreichen
dass Süddeutschland ist vielfältig und
bunt und es wird ganz verschiedene
Lösungen geben aber verbundene Lösungen
haben einen Vorteil gegenüber der
individual
Heizungsanlage sie können sich aus
verschiedenen Quellen speisen sie können
Geothermie nehmen sie können power to
heat nehmen sie können große angekunden
nehmen sie können Biomasseanlagen
Einschalten sie können Solarthermie dazu
nehmen und je nach Preisgefälle und
Preisgestaltung und Angebot kann man
verschiedene Wärmequellen bündeln und
das ist ein Vorteil das ist auch ein
ökonomischer und sicherheitspolitischer
Vorteil man geht eben immer zum
günstigsten Angebot oder auch wenn eins
ausfällt keine Ahnung Sturm auf der
Nordsee irgendwelche Biomasse Schiffe
kommen nicht an dann nimmt man halt mehr
aus Power durch was auch immer das hat
man natürlich bei der einzelnen Anlage
nicht und insofern glaube ich dass viele
Kommunen und noch einmal überprüfen
werden ob sie diesen Vorteil nicht für
sich nutzen werden und dann dieses
dieses fernglasystem ausrollen auch da
gibt es eine sonderförder Meinung darauf
will ich kurz Hinweisen bew heißt das
Programm Bundesprogramm erneuerbare
Wärme die die Amt die die Ausrollen von
Fernwärmenetzen und die dekarbonisierung
der fernwärmespezifisch fördert also mit
fernwärmer
zumindest da vielen Dank für den Besuch
in der Bundespressekonferenz vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse und einen schönen Tag
noch